i went back recently uh rachel peterson
is our chief researcher
and she pulled up 35 pages of material
on the actual black lives matter
organization and when he's founded by
three marxists
and when you read about their real
beliefs you begin to understand
they live in an alternative worldview
they live in a world where the police
are really
very dangerous and they don't quite have
an explanation for all the other people
get killed because you're
if you're an african-american male
you're 300 times more likely
to be shot by a criminal than by the
police uh but that doesn't matter
because
you know the police are an extension of
the authoritarian power of the white
male dominated culture which is what
they're really mad about
this has come up with almost all of my
guests because everyone at this point
basically agrees that the media is
crumbling they've done this to
themselves they
they seem to double down every time
instead of you know having a moment of
self reflection
but are you worried that if the new york
times fails if
cnn if just the media and then the rest
of the institutions because that then
spreads to academia and everywhere else
that if these institutions all crumble
you know you know we almost have no
way of having a national ethos at some
level
well look i think there are other
institutions that emerge
i think there's an amazing amount of
information now
on the internet through facebook and
youtube and a bride
twitter although twitter's very there's
a lot of hostility in it
but uh you know and you have places like
c-span which really are
uh remarkably neutral in fact i have
watched several trump speeches on c-span
you also have an ability to stream
things the president uh streams a lot of
his speeches and
puts them out watch his speeches uh his
stream from the white house
we also frankly during the lockdown got
into watching both the
saint peter's uh and uh the basilica in
washington
because they were streaming mass so
you're entering a world
of dramatically more media not lesbian
just as your show
is another example of more media not
less media but
we're going to have a really deep split
because uh we're in the middle of a
cultural civil war
and there's just no question in my mind
that this is the most divided we've been
since the election of lincoln in 1860
and his re-election in 1864 and that
part of the reason i wrote
uh trump and the american future is that
i really do believe that what happens
this fall
may do more to shape america's future
than any election
since 1864 uh and i say that
because i think that the biden
pelosi schumer team will be so
radical that we would not recognize the
country within two or three years
they would have moved us so far to the
left do you think that it's the biden
schumer pelosi team that are actually
the true radicals or do you think it's
the it's the bernie crew and the aoc
crew beneath them that's sort of just
shifting them that way or do you really
feel like they
are actually that radical it's a little
hard to tell these days if they're a
little more
old school and the you know the tail is
wagging the dog basically
yeah i mean a little bit like saying
when you get when you get run over by
the truck
you know do you think the driver was
deliberately trying to run really
he got run over when schumer the other
day
came out for the 10 cut in defense
spending which sanders is offering as an
amendment
uh and when pelosi brought up a bill
which 207 democrats voted for
that gives a 1200 bonus to every illegal
immigrant don't you think about this
207 democrats voted to give a twelve
hundred dollar bonus check
to every illegal immigrant i mean you
have to wonder
these people just crazy um
biden has said that he would
sign the pelosi bill which is a three
trillion dollar
very radical bill he certainly didn't
see biden
criticizing the looters and the violence
in fact
13 of biden's staff actually helped bail
out looters
and violent people in uh minneapolis
uh so i just you know i think there's a
pattern
in trump in the american future i put in
chapter that the democrats love
criminals and hate police
and i think if you look at seattle
minneapolis chicago
new york i think that that's the
objective evidence
so as we watch these progressive cities
crumble
the the several you just named there and
we can we can go on the list
all the cities with the worst violence
and the worst gun violence and the
highest rates of murders they're they're
all i think 19 out of 20
or something like that are progressive
progressive-run cities do you
sense that sort of what those mayors and
and the governors to another extent want
is they want the chaos so that trump has
to bring in
troops or the national guard like
they're almost laying out a trap so that
he looks like
the authoritarian that they wish him to
be
no i i think i mean i don't think they
mind that happening but i don't think
that's what they're doing
i think that the left really has this
fantasy image of how the world works
and they really think that if only there
were no policemen it's
sort of like the the democratic mayor of
seattle
who said that we were gonna have a
summer of love when they created the
autonomous district now
poor people got killed and she gave up
on that although ironically
she didn't really give up on it until
the demonstrators came to her home one
night
suddenly when they were surrounding her
house yeah that's
she said something that's real but i
think
part of it is that their their radical
left-wing ideology
doesn't allow them to deal with reality
so you end up with
let's cut the budget of the new york
police department a billion dollars
when there were i think um 13 people
shot yeah on monday
chicago has few too few policemen not
too many
and they have a dozen or more people
shot every weekend
um you know after all the problems in
minneapolis
they're now moving to uh dissolve the
police department
and and in my mind
you know if you if you stop and say i
mean walk me through this
uh there's an armed gunman uh it's two
o'clock in the morning
you're going to send social workers to
chat with the government i just need to
understand
how their world view works but but
i went back recently rachel peterson is
our chief researcher
and she pulled up 35 pages of material
on the actual black lives matter
organization
and when he's founded by three marxists
uh
and when you read about their real
beliefs you begin to understand
they live in an alternative worldview
they live in a world where the police
are really
very dangerous and they don't quite have
an explanation for all the other people
get killed because you're
if you're an african-american male
you're 300 times more likely
to be shot by a criminal than by the
police uh but that doesn't matter
because
you know the police are an extension of
the authoritarian power of the white
male dominated culture which is what
they're really mad about
uh whereas if you just happen to get
killed by your neighbor that doesn't
really count so
you know an eight-year-old girl gets
killed in atlanta well that's
unfortunate
but it's not something that black lives
matter is going to do anything about but
she wasn't killed by a policeman
a seven-year-old gets killed in chicago
well that's really unfortunate
but it's not really a political event
because she wasn't killed by a policeman
so you really have this very weird
period underway
where the left has no
model to explain how they would achieve
peace just as by the way they have no
model to explain how they would educate
children you look at
baltimore which has the fourth most
expensive school system in the country
and has entire buildings in which not a
single child can pass the exam not one
to which biden's comments this week were
maybe we need to quit um testing
because after all it probably makes them
feel bad that they didn't pass the test
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling check out our
politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell